Bring up professor. Whoops. Okay, there
we go. What's up, man?
>> What's up?
>> You're a Muslim?
>> Yes, of course.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. So, what do you think of the
topic, man? Did Jesus mention Muhammad?
>> Most certainly.
>> Okay. Where did he where did he mention
Muhammad?
>> First of all, can you read my name again
just to make sure you know who I am?
>> Uh, no.
>> No, because you're talking to someone
educated.
>> Okay.
>> You must emphasize who I am.
>> I like that. I like that. But no, just
go ahead and show
>> when I cook
>> when you go ahead. I'm
>> going to cook you like a chicken stew.
>> Like a chicken stew.
>> I'm going to boil.
>> Yes. I'm going to boil the broth and sip
on it like soup.
>> Why? Why not pork stew?
>> Because Jesus cast the demons into the
swine. And if you like to eat demons, go
ahead.
>> Oh, so you're saying so swine are
demons?
>> 100%.
>> So okay. Okay.
>> So you're saying you're a demon then?
>> So So you're saying So you're saying So
you're saying the Bible gives the
correct story of Jesus? I'm saying it
gives accounts which may or may not be
accurate.
>> No, you said cuz I'm talking to someone,
you know, educated. You said that Jesus
cast demons into swine. You said that as
a fact. So that means that the Bible is
giving accurate information about Jesus
and what he did. Correct.
>> In parts of it. Yes. 100%. So in that
same in that same passage when the
demons said that Jesus is the son of God
and he told them uh to shut up because
it's not time for that to be revealed.
That's also true. Him affirming that
he's the son of God. Correct in that
same passage.
>> No.
>> Oh. So then how you know that the part
about him throwing this those same
demons into the swine is true because
it's the same it's the same passage,
same verse.
>> Okay. And if I answer your question,
would you now become a Muslim?
>> Depends.
>> I'll prove you wrong. Depends. Prove me
wrong about what? I'm going about what
you said, brother. But you try to be
clever there trying to say, "Oh, in the
same passage it says this, so that must
be true because a demon said it."
>> No, cuz Jesus affirmed. Jesus Jesus
affirmed what the demon said, brother.
>> Okay. So when Satan tempted Jesus, Yeah.
Satan telling the truth.
>> Why Why are you going to what Satan did?
>> Because Satan was a demon as well.
>> Did Did Jesus affirm what Satan said?
>> You're giving. You're scared.
>> Oh. against a real professor today.
[laughter] You're really scared. Instead
of stayed on poison, I'm shivering. I'm
shivering.
>> This is your classic maneuver.
>> Okay. I I just want to know is G was is
Jesus correct? Is that the correct
rendition of Jesus when he affirmed what
the demon said about him being the son
of God who has authority to cast them
and to torture them in the end times.
Remember, unfortunately, modern
Christians such as yourself
anthropomorphize
Jesus and any
>> we do what?
>> You anthropomorphize Jesus.
>> What What does it mean to
anthropomorphize?
>> You give um God a human form of some
form.
>> Oh, so you're saying Jesus is God and we
are anthrop anthropomorphizing God when
we do that for Jesus. No, I'm saying
when people say the son of God, you
create as in
>> you know too well that the father means
the father of creation. Yeah. Not the
father of a child as in begotten.
>> I don't know how we got here made up.
>> Professor, that's that's irrelevant.
That's that's irrelevant. The question
was Jesus. Is that a correct rendition
of Jesus in this story where he casts
the uh the demons into the swine? In
that same passage, they say that he's
the son of God and Jesus affirms what
they say about him and that he's the one
who's going to judge them on judgment
day and cast them into outer darkness.
Is that all true?
>> Yes. But you're so you believe
>> you believe that Jesus is the judge on
judgment day.
>> Would you allow me to complete my answer
or are you going to interrupt me
constantly? I'm just excited to be
talking to someone so educated. That's
all. So,
>> you've talked to me many times.
>> Yes.
>> I've transformed. I've transformed and
transfigured on the mount of Gol Gotha
like you've evolved. You and your homies
did.
>> You You've evolved. You're You're not a
Pikachu anymore. You're a Raichu now.
You You're not
>> I'm a Muslim.
>> Nice. You're not a Charmander no more.
You a Charizard, ain't you? I like you,
dude. I like you. You done You done hit
your You went into into your little
cocoon and you just broke out. You know
what I'm saying? Is that what happened?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> You see how many moon cycles I'm showing
right now, Avery?
>> Man. Yeah, man.
>> You You operate in swine cycles. I
operate on moon cycles.
>> Hey, just be careful not to get your
moon split, man. Listen.
>> Yeah, the moon the moon and the moon had
split the sun.
>> Don't get your moon split though. That's
>> Oh, I like the comment from M4 Elements.
That was funny. They're saying I'm
comedy, but you're put on your
hat. Are you kidding me? You're awesome.
You should come around way more often.
>> I did come around more often, but then
your Christians couldn't handle me, so
they had to start blocking me.
>> Blocking you and stuff. Yeah, that makes
sense.
>> Yes,
>> I was Christian Darren.
>> It was probably the Cathol specifically,
huh?
>> Me and your friend Darren got along
really well until your friend Jay the
Hindu blocked us.
>> Jay the Hindu.
>> So unfort J49er the Hindu.
>> Yes, he blocked me. I call him the
cowpiss drinker and he blocked people.
[laughter]
>> But do you call yourself the camel piss
drinker?
>> No, because uh we don't have camels in
the United Kingdom.
>> But you have it in Islam, right?
>> Meat.
>> But in Islam, you can drink camel piss,
right? [clears throat]
>> Well, bear grills. Who's a British
citizen?
>> No, not bear grills. I'm talking about
you as a Muslim, you can drink camel
piss, right?
>> If you're dehydrated and you need a
source of sustenance, of course.
>> What about just for like medicinal
purposes? Can you drink it for medicinal
purposes?
>> No, I prefer honey. Yeah, but I'm saying
in in Islam, are you able to drink camel
piss for medicinal purposes?
>> In Christianity, are you able to get
baptized with dirty water?
>> Well, look, professor, you did a great
job educating us. You did a great job,
man. You did a great job showcasing
Islam. Thank you so much, brother. That
was awesome, man. Thank you for coming
up. That was a great way to start the
show off. Great way to start the show
off, man. I mean, who who can't who
can't love a guy like that? Who can't
love a guy? Perfect. full Muslim
exemplary
showcase of Islam.
>> Love it. Love it. Love it. Love it. Love
it. Love it. All right, let's bring up
our next guest.
>> Yo,
>> how you [snorts] doing?
>> Yo, I'm senior. Are you one of those
speaker corner leaders?
>> No, not me. No.
>> Oh, okay. Well, I just wanted to like
you like would you like to solve my
riddle?
>> Yeah.
>> Are you going to kick me? Right.
>> I want to solve your riddle.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Okay. Riddle did it. I knew and he's
gone. What is up with this man? Goodness
gracious. Maybe I should have took it
off. Maybe I should have stayed away on
a Friday. I should have known, man. It's
Friday. I I I should have known. I
should have known. I should I should
have known it would be like this on a on
a Friday, man. Good. Googly, moogly.
Hey.
>> Hey. What's going on?
>> Nothing much, man. Nothing much. How are
you doing today?
>> Doing well. Doing well. Thanks for
having me. Okay.
>> Awesome. So, how would you like to
engage with the topic today?
>> Yeah, sure. So, I guess to preface,
which cannons do you follow? I guess if
I'm using the right term
>> any of them.
>> Any of them. So like do you use the
oriental house church whole cannon or
like the Coptics and Syriak church or
>> you can use all of that. It doesn't
matter.
>> Use all that. All right. So are you
familiar with Kabal Akbar?
>> What's that?
>> Um it's essentially a predomination.
There's actually you were engaged on it.
There's a video with you there. I was
outside at a function where you had a
conversation in regards to it of how
Muhammad was mentioned and how a rabbi
at the time um actually converted to
Islam and you read the first passage of
Genesis. It was the book of Genesis that
predicted that he would come and and you
were there. I I saw you there reading
it. Do you forget?
>> Yeah. I don't I don't remember this at
all. You said Genesis is where Jesus
mentioned Muhammad,
>> right? It's it's not necessarily Jesus,
but Jesus is one with God, right? So it
was messaged through him and it was God
in first person speaking. So it was one
of those
>> Wait, slow down. Slow down for me. You
you believe that Jesus is and to be
clear, you're a Muslim. Is that right?
>> Right.
>> Okay. So you you believe that Jesus is
one with God, like he's one in essence.
>> No, I'm saying off of the if if you're
going with the ideology that you're
reading these passages when God is
speaking in certain cases as a
Christian, right, you're going to assume
that you're reading in the voice of God.
Is that right? when speaking it's Jesus
speaking right
>> not necessarily so where are the
demarcations because is are there mutual
exclusions between God and Jesus
>> well if you're saying God is in the
father then there's a distinction
between the persons of Jesus and the
father so just because the father is
speaking doesn't mean Jesus is speaking
>> so it's not a bi it's not like a a
constant birectional thing
>> I don't know what you mean by that
>> like birectional between Jesus speaking
and God speaking it goes both ways So it
goes up and down, right? It's it's like
person A and person B. It's birectional
between both. When person B is speaking,
he's not speaking on A and B's behalf.
It's exclusive. Now, if it's inclusive,
it includes when B is speaking, it
presupposes A and B speaking. Is that
right?
>> I didn't understand that. So ju just to
keep it simple, when the father is
speaking, the father's speaking. He's
not the son.
>> Right. So one exist in the other, but
the other does not necessarily
encapsulate everything else. It's one's
exclusionary. So A can exist outside of
B. But
>> these are these are two distinct persons
that we're talking about, brother. Just
keep it simple. Is that like is that a
little
>> But Jesus said he's the right hand of
God
>> is what I'm trying to say.
>> So that shows that these that means that
he's a distinct person from the one he's
at the right hand of. Right.
>> So if he's at the right hand of God, is
he not God? Is is it says when it says
book
and God are one?
>> Just really quicker.
>> Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Because the word God is not univocal.
It's not used in just one way. So when
you see that he's at the right hand of
God, God isn't using is being used in
reference to the father, right? So um in
context of saying that Jesus is at the
right hand of the father showing the
distinction between the persons. So the
question is where does where does Jesus
mention Muhammad?
>> So I understand that. So the the concept
is I'll try to pull it up here. Give me
a moment.
>> Okay,
>> I'm going to step down pull it up here
cuz I do have an email but give me one
moment. I'm going to come right back up.
I'm not deflecting or running away. I'm
still here.
>> Okay. All right. I guess uh he'll
request back up when he's ready. So,
where does Jesus meet your M?
>> Uh no, that that was going to be
>> that's that's the topic today.
>> No, I want to talk about something else.
>> Oh, okay.
>> You were talking about the other day how
>> No, today where did where does Jesus
mention Muhammad? That's the topic
today. [clears throat]
>> No, no, I don't know about that.
>> You don't know anything about that?
>> No. Are you familiar with the Quran
verse that says that Jesus mentioned
Ahmed to come after him? Chapter 61.
>> No.
>> Really? You never heard of this before?
>> I probably heard of it, but I haven't
like read the full Quran to the fullest.
So,
>> how long have you been a Muslim?
>> Uh, like my whole life?
>> You've been a Muslim your whole life and
you haven't read the Quran yet? It's
only 114 chapters.
>> I'm 13, bro.
>> Oh, jeez. You're young, man.
>> Yeah.
>> Honestly, you're a little too young to
be up here. I could get flagged.
>> I'm confident. I didn't say you're not
confident. If anything, you would have
to come um on my YouTube because I I
could get flagged for having you here.
But look, I'm going to share this verse
with you, but I can't have you up too
long. So, it says, "And remember, this
is the Quran, chapter 61:6." It says,
"Remember when Jesus, son of Mary, said,
>> "Wait, where were you getting your
translation from?"
>> Uh, this is a Yusf Ali translation.
>> All right.
>> It doesn't matter what translation you
use, they all say the same thing in this
verse. Okay? Remember when Jesus son of
Mary said, "Oh children of Israel, I am
the messenger of Allah
uh sent to you confirming the Torah
before me and giving glad tidings of a
messenger to come after me whose name
shall be Ahmed." So the Quran says that
Jesus said Ahmed is going to come after
him. Somebody named Ahmed. Right? Now if
Jesus never said this, then this would
mean that the Quran is false. Right? If
Jesus never said that Quran is false.
>> Yeah. Would you agree?
>> Yeah. But he [clears throat]
that it's talking about the original
scripture, not the new scriptures.
>> Yeah. So, this is what what you're going
to have to do, bro. You're going to have
to show me. You're going to have to show
me where Jesus ever said this ever
mentioned to come after.
>> Yeah. He may have in the original
Aramaic scripture, but he might have not
in the new in the new books cuz you guys
changed it up.
>> Yeah. So for you to say that something
is changed up would mean that you know
what the original said.
>> No, nobody does.
>> So then you So then you can't say that
it was changed up.
>> Yeah. But it can't be the same.
>> Why not?
>> Cuz it's in a different language. And
>> so is this what I'm reading? Is this not
the same Quran? Cuz it's in English.
>> I'm not talking about the Quran. Yeah,
but we have the original in Arabic.
>> Yes. I'm I'm asking based on what you
said. Can you stop moving so much in
your microphone? It's giving a lot of
feedback. You said that it has it can't
be the same because it's in a different
language. So, I'm reading the Quran in
English right now. Does this mean that
I'm reading a different Quran? It's a
whole changed Quran.
>> No, it I'm saying like it can't be the
same not only about the translations cuz
you guys changed some of the wording in
the Bible.
>> How do you know that wording was
changed? Have you seen the original
wording?
>> No, but in
>> You see how you see how silly that
>> recorded that?
>> Hold on. You see how you see how silly
that is to say that something was
without seeing the original? How how
would you know if something's changed if
you haven't seen the original?
>> It was some of it was changed recently.
>> I don't think that you're hearing what
I'm what I'm asking you, brother.
>> Yeah, I I hear you. But some of it was
changed recently. So,
>> how do you know it was changed?
>> Cuz everybody says it is. It's mass
transmission.
>> All right. And everybody says the Quran
has changed, too. Does that mean the
Quran's been changed?
>> No, nobody says it.
>> Yeah, I say it. A bunch of people online
say it. A bunch of Everybody says it.
>> Yeah. Are they Muslim? Have you ever
heard a Muslim say the Quran has been
changed?
>> Yes.
>> A Muslim say the Quran has been changed?
>> In real life or Tik Tok or where?
>> Real life. Real life and Tik Tok
actually.
>> All right. Uh where like channel name?
Well, nobody said the Quran has been
changed. It's been the same. It's been
in Arabic.
>> But I don't I don't think
>> the original language.
>> I don't think it's going to be fair for
me to talk to you. You're not. You got
to You got to do a little bit more
studying first, okay? And then we could
talk. All right. I'll be I'll be around,
Lord willing, for some years. Hopefully
when you
>> Yeah, but like you kicked off the only
guy that was actually debating you
really goodly.
>> Who you professor? You kicked him off.
>> Professor was debating me good.
>> Yeah.
>> What what what good point did he make?
>> Dude, you asked him the are we able to
drink camel piss and then he asked you
are you able to baptize in dirty water?
That's basically that's the same thing.
Oh, so baptizing in dirty water is the
same as drinking camel piss.
>> No, but it's like same quality like you
shower dirty water or drink dirty water.
>> And you're saying that that's the same
as drinking camel piss?
>> Dirty water is basically dirty water.
>> So then why does Muhammad say that you
could drink camel piss then?
>> If you're depriving of thirst, you
wouldn't drink camel piss. You just die.
>> No, he says you could drink camel piss
and that it's healthy for you.
>> You don't even know how to filter.
Right. Right. But yeah, if
>> Poor young kid uh Mus Muso, welcome
back.
>> What's up? You remember me? Of course.
So where does Jesus mention Muhammad?
>> In the in jail.
>> Where? What passage?
>> It doesn't exist. Do you know where the
in jail is?
>> What is it?
>> You don't know where the in jail is?
>> You know what? I think that what you
have done is done me a great favor.
>> Because you have just entered our
favorite segment of the day, which is
God.
Welcome back ladies and gentlemen. We
are here with another contestant on
what's the NGL. We got Musul here who
says that Jesus mentioned Ahmed in the
NGO. However, the NGL doesn't exist and
then he asked me if I even know what the
angel is. So if he knows that the angel
does not exist, that must mean that he
knows what it is since he can tell me
what it's not. So Mousil, what's the
angel, man? Well, in Jews, the scripture
that uh uh Jesus got the revelations to
and uh he taught and then it got
corrupted. Uh and yeah.
>> Okay. What was that scripture
>> now? Which people walking now with the
cross around their neck and they believe
in human sacrifice and
>> that's all nice and all. You're not
telling me what the angel is. What is
that? What is that scripture that Jesus
was was preaching? What was that? the
scripture it was in line with the our
belief in the Quran because uh it was
the same message uh to worship one god
but um we don't have the complete same
scripture since it has been corrupted.
>> Have you ever seen it before the angel?
>> I I haven't read it before. No.
>> Have you ever touched it?
>> No.
>> You ever smelt it?
>> I don't know what you're talking about.
>> Have you ever smelt the angel? Have you
ever captured its scent?
>> No.
>> Have you?
>> I have. At least I believe I have. So if
you have never touched it, never felt
it, never smelt it, you never dealt it.
>> You're hilarious, man. [laughter]
I forgot to laugh. Yeah, but no.
>> Okay. So you never dealt it. You ain't
touched it. You ain't felt it. You ain't
smelt it. You ain't dealt it.
>> But you're telling me that it's been
changed. It's corrupted. And you're
trying to tell me what it what it had in
it and all this kind of stuff.
>> So it's hard for me to believe because
I'm not seeing or hearing any evidence
backing up what you're saying. Uh-huh.
>> So,
>> okay.
>> If if you never touched it, read it,
seen it, smelt it, been in the presence
of it,
>> dealt it,
>> dealt it. How in the world can you tell
me what's in it?
>> All right. That's a good question.
>> Thank you.
>> I will read you a verse from the Quran.
What we think about this so you can
understand my view. All right.
>> Okay.
>> One second. Let me just take my second
device.
>> So, this verse is going to tell us what
the angel is.
>> It just give you a description of what
you believe uh happened. I I'm I'm I'm
honestly not interested in a description
of what you believe. I'm interested in
what the angel actually is. Does the
Quran tell you what it actually is or
no?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. That's what I'm looking for.
>> Well, that's what I'm doing.
>> Awesome. Okay. So, you got the verse.
>> Uh yeah, I got it. So, uh chapter 546.
And we sent following in their
footsteps. Jesus.
>> Jesus son of Mary. And we gave him the
confirming what came before him. And we
gave him the gospel confirming the Torah
which which is the guidance and light.
What does it tell us what that gospel
is, bro? Cuz that doesn't tell me
anything.
>> So in the in that gospel, we believe
things have been mentioned.
>> I don't care what you believe. I only
care about what you can show me with
proof.
>> God the logic.
>> Logic. God the logic.
>> I I I like guys like you. I really do.
See, a lot of you guys don't think that.
I love guys like you. The
>> god logic one second. The arrogant ones,
the dumb ones with arrogance at the same
time is you guys are the funnest to bust
up, you know.
>> All right. Wait a second. Illogic. All
right.
>> So, stop with the we believe. We
believe.
>> Stop. Stop with all that. What actually
is that gospel that Jesus had?
>> So, is it a yes or no answer or
something? Is that true? Is it It's not
a yes or no question. So, if you let me
speak God logic, then I will.
>> You have a chance to speak. If the next
words that come out of your mouth is not
telling me what the angel actually is,
then you can kiss. Go kiss the rock.
I'll send you on your way. So tell me
what the angel actually is. Not what you
believe, not what you think. What is it?
>> All right. God of logic. So about the
angel, um, it teaches about the not
about paganism like you
>> get off my stage. Go kiss the Cabba like
your pagan prophet did. Go and circle
the Cabba like your pagans did and have
fun with that. Love you, man. Enjoy
Islam.